So we now have, lo and behold, what a surprise.
We have audio with subtitles of the confrontation
between Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
that happened on stage at the end of Tuesday
nights, democratic [inaudible]
presidential debate.
There is so much to say about this.
I showed the video to you yesterday and we
are showing it again now of this moment after
the debate during which Bernie denied having
told Elizabeth Warren that a woman can't be
president and Elizabeth Warren completely
ignoring that, reacting to how she felt when
Bernie told her that day that a woman cannot
be president.
So at the end of the debate, Elizabeth Warren
went over to Bernie.
Bernie extended his hand for a handshake.
Warren refused to shake it and said something
which led to a brief confrontation before
Bernie kind of did it, forget it, sign and
then walked away.
We now have a version with audio and subtitles
telling us exactly what was said and I want
to divide the analysis into two parts and
then we're moving the hell on from this.
Okay.
First is the content and then is the context
because both deserves some discussion here
to start with.
Let's look at the 16 seconds in question that
took place right after the debate.
Now with audio and subtitles,
you told me a wire on national TV helped me
a liar on national.
Let's not do it right now.
You want to have that discussion?
We'll have that discussion you called [inaudible].
You told me.
All right, let's not do it.
I don't want to get nailed.
I just want to say hybrid.
Yeah, good.
Okay.
Okay, so Elizabeth Warren accuses Burnie of
calling her a nigh a liar on national TV.
Bernie says, well, you called me a liar and
then quickly says, let's not do this right
now.
We can do this at some other point and then
walks away.
So before we move on to the serious stuff,
by the way, fan boy Tom Stier saying, Hey
Bernie, just saying hi and Bernie's reaction
of, yeah, good.
Okay.
Is is hilarious.
It's like a kid awkwardly asking about having
a cookie while mom and dad are arguing with
each other, but let's get onto the analysis.
Let's first analyze the content.
If we assume that everybody is acting in good
faith first of all and then we'll get to that.
We've been trying to figure out, Bernie says
he didn't say it.
Warren says he did say it.
It's hard to imagine that Bernie's belief
is women can't be president, so maybe there
was something more that explains the whole
thing, so at its face, if you asked me what's
the most likely scenario, if we assume everyone's
acting in good faith and hold that for a second,
we'll get back to that.
The most likely scenario is the reason why
they both say the other is lying is that both
Bernie and Warren believe that they remember
it going different ways.
Bernie believes he didn't say it and Warren
believes that she did say it or they have
totally different understandings of what the
context was.
Neither one of them likely remembers the word
for word of what was said.
This was well over a year ago at this point.
They have different understandings of what
was meant or implied.
It doesn't change that it's a fabricated controversy
that only helps Joe Biden.
It seems to have been crafted by CNN, but
that's at least an explanation as to if they
both are in good faith saying you're lying.
No, no, you're lying.
The most likely scenario is they don't exactly
remember.
They have different interpretations of the
context and both believe that they are telling
the truth.
Here's where it starts to get slippery for
me and this is where we have to add in the
context and other things that we know.
Warren knew that she was miked up at this
point when this took place on stage.
Every politician knows that when the show
ends and it's been 15 seconds and you're still
wearing a mic and the room is filled with
cameras, you operate as if you are being recorded
and she was being recorded and she chose to
do this while miked in front of a camera.
Just seconds after the debate, the cloud,
uh, the crowd is still clapping.
Warren is front and center.
She confronts Bernie Sanders.
She knows exactly what she's doing.
While Bernie is going in for a handshake,
he seems genuinely surprised that she's doing
this on stage and says, let's discuss it later.
So for me, it's every indication that any
disagreement about what was actually said
is being handled in the most public way possible
by Elizabeth Warren, which suggests, or at
least makes me question whether this was a
crafted and coordinated campaign between the
Warren campaign and CNN.
By the way, here's a clip of CNN.
Erin Burnett actually saying the Warren campaign
leaked to this, to CNN.
Take a look.
Warren had no problem with this story yesterday.
It was clearly leaked by her team to CNN.
It was, it came out more than a year after
the meeting.
It came out on the Eve of a debate.
Uh, this is pretty clear.
Uh, she knew about this.
She, she sanctioned it.
Everything around it indicates that, why is
she pumping the brakes now indicating don't
want to talk about this anymore.
We're all cool.
Uh, because this is probably the last thing
she wants to talk to islands about, uh, before
they vote.
So then a couple of thoughts on the outcome
because that's really what matters here.
First of all, it's irresponsible not to mention
the context.
Okay?
There is no chance in hell that the conversation
was an isolated statement by Bernie where
Bernie said women can't win the presidency
and Warren says, I think a woman can win and
that's the full conversation.
Nobody clarifies anything.
Does Bernie mean women cannot be president
in some kind of base way, which seems inconceivable?
Does he mean sexism and Trumpists in 2020
would make it tough for a woman to win, which
is a reasonable opinion to have.
You could agree, disagree, but okay.
And that being said, you know Warren, when
this was brought up during the debate on Tuesday,
Warren said that she knows her friend Bernie.
Bernie is her friend.
If she knows him the way she claims to, she
should be saying, hold on a second.
Based on my long friendship with Bernie, he
would never suggest women cannot do the job
of president they that they cannot win an
election.
This was a misunderstanding about strategy
strategy, but Bernie is not a sexist and she
hasn't done that, which is another sign that
the Warren campaign is participating in this.
If this ends up being a Biden Warren ticket,
like if Biden ends up being the nominee and
selects Elizabeth Warren as his running mate,
I think circumstantially it would throw more
fuel on the fire.
That makes us question what coordination went
into this, but the more important thing here
is this doesn't seem to be helping Elizabeth
Warren.
It's also not likely to help Bernie Sanders
much either.
As I said before, the entire narrative fills
corporate media with other stuff.
It takes attention off of Joe Biden offering
basically a status quo center left platform
that is not what millions of Americans want,
but it is what the elites want.
It's what the DNC wants.
It's what is really the underlying goal here.
This all reinforces Joe Biden and it's working
very, very well.